SPEAKER: OK.
So, as far as clarifications,
and hints and comments,
and so on on the homework, these
are kind of general comments.
One is don't lose your common sense.
That doesn't mean you can
rely only on common sense,
because we're going to see over
and over again in this course a lot
of counterintuitive results that
may seem to defy common sense.
But that doesn't mean--
just because we're
doing some counterintuitive
stuff sometimes
doesn't mean you should
abandon common sense.
And I also mean, I mean
this not only in terms of
do your answers makes sense, but also
just in terms of being reasonable.
Like a couple of you asked about
calculators and things like that.
On the homework you can use
calculators if you want,
but it shouldn't be
necessary for the most part.
Once in a while it will
be obvious that you
should use a calculator for that part.
On the exams, there's no calculators
allowed but also no calculators needed.
So, either on the homework or on the
exam, you should use some common sense.
For example, if you have 52 choose
5, it's perfectly fine to leave it
as 52 choose 5.
Certainly on the exam,
common sense, I don't expect
you to compute 52 choose 5 by hand.
On the homework, if you're
curious what the number is,
you can do this very easily
using a calculator or a computer.
But you can also leave
it as 52 choose 5, which
has the virtue of being what I call--
I call this self-annotating.
Now, 52 choose 5, it's
some big number, right?
If I just gave you that big number,
it would be hard to know what it was,
but 52 choose 5, it's already making
you think, oh, this has something
to do with choosing 5 out of 52.
So this is self-annotating,
which is good.
You could leave it that way.
On the other hand--
so this you would leave.
But common sense would be, well,
if you have 4 divided by 2 times 1,
I would prefer, either on
the homework or on the exam,
I would prefer that
you simplify it to 2.
Occasionally, you may need
to add fractions, so 1/2
plus 1/3 I'm assuming you
can do without a calculator.
But you're never going to have ugly,
tedious stuff on the exam, certainly.
And if it's tedious on the homework,
then you can use a calculator for that.
And that's also a hint.
If, on the midterm or
final, you find yourself
doing all these massive calculations
with huge fractions and things
like, that then there's
probably something wrong.
So that's just a
clarification about that.
Second, useful throughout
the course, do check answers,
and I'll talk more about checking
answers at different points.
But just briefly, checking
answers does not mean go through
and look what you did
and say that looks OK.
Like do the same thing twice, right?
Because if you made a
mistake the first time,
you're probably not going to detect
it when you look through it again.
Checking an answer means trying
special cases, things like that,
thinking of another approach.
A lot of problems can be
solved in more than one method,
and if you get the same
answer, you're happy.
If you get a different answer,
then you have to think harder
and you learn something from that.
So the best advice for
this is, especially,
by doing simple and extreme cases.
Like you might have a problem that you
have some answer in terms of n, and k,
and q, and w, and if
you plug in n equals 1
and it's completely obviously wrong,
then that's useful information, right?
But most students don't bother
to just plug in n equals 1
and see if it makes sense.
So simple and extreme cases,
The third thing, I've never seen it
given a name or any emphasis at all,
but it's very, very useful to label.
And let me tell you what I mean by
label people, objects, whatever.
Let me tell you what I mean by that.
So on a lot of the homework problems
and a lot of problems in this course,
let's say, well, you have a group
of n people, or a group of n elk,
or gummy bears, or
something, and you're just
asking about this collection of
objects, or people, or animals.
And all I mean by this is
just, if you have n people--
so the problem will just say we
have n people, blah, blah, blah--
then assume that they're labeled
with the numbers 1 up to n.
Very, very simple, but
that's extremely useful.
So basically, you have
this collection of people.
Now, in the problem I'm not going to
give names to all of these n people,
and n could be a billion
or anything, right?
But assume that they each have--
just think of this as an ID number,
or social security number, or whatever.
So you definitely want to
do that with the people.
That's going to be helpful with the elk.
And you have a homework
problem about balls in a jar.
There's a certain number of red balls
and a certain number of green balls.
It's very useful if you, for example--
you can choose your own notation.
It's very useful, for example
though, you could say let's number
or label the red balls 1
through r, and the green balls
r plus 1 through r plus g, for example.
You can do something like that, and
you're referring to specific balls.
Now, this might seem
very obvious, but I'm
stressing it just because
I've seen students
very often get confused because
they're not thinking of this labeling.
And for people it's pretty clear.
Even if you have identical twins, you
can still tell them apart in some way,
right?
So perfect sense with people.
People start to get more
confused when we talk about this
for, like, balls and
the question is are they
indistinguishable or
distinguishable, and whatever.
So suppose you have 10
green balls in a jar
and they all look
completely identical to you.
I'm not actually saying that the
numbers are actually written on them.
They may look completely
identical to you,
but the point is that, as far
as probability is concerned,
as far as nature is concerned,
it behaves as if they
are distinguishable and labeled.
And that that's going to
give you the correct answers.
Whereas, if you just
say, well, they're there,
they're completely identical,
so they're indistinguishable,
you'll run into trouble.
So it helps to think about the labeling.
And I think that is also relevant
for the robberies and districts.
There are six districts, six robberies.
I think the best way
to think about it is
to imagine numbering the district's
1 to 6, number the robberies 1 to 6,
and think about it that way.
Someone asked me whether robberies are
distinguishable or indistinguishable.
Well, the problem doesn't designate
this robbery was this type
and this was this type.
They may look very similar, but
they're different robberies.
They didn't occur at exactly the same
time, exactly the same circumstances.
There's something that
distinguishes them.
You may as well give
each one an ID number,
as if you'll file a report on each one.
You have robbery 1 through 6, and
thinking about how it will work better.
We'll come back to this
issue of indistinguishability
later because it's
actually quite subtle.
And just a quick clarification
about the problem about the teams
you're splitting up.
I think it's clearly worded,
but just to make sure everyone
understands, if I say you
have 10 people and you
want to split them into a
team of 4 and a team of 6--
let me just do as a quick
example because there's actually
some interesting things here.
It's a bit of a hint
but it's also useful.
So suppose we have 10 people and
I want to split into a team of 6
and a team of 4.
And I want to know how many
ways are there to do that.
Well, then it's just 10 choose 4.
Because I pick the team of 4,
whoever's left is the team of 6.
That's it.
Of course, I could have
said pick the team of 6,
and whoever's left is the team of 4.
So I could have said 10 choose 6.
We actually just proved that
10 choose 4 equals 10 choose 6.
Because I just counted the same
thing in two different ways,
it must be the same.
I mean, you can check this.
This is 10 factorial over 6 factorial
4 factorial, and so is this,
so it's true.
But we proved it just
by thinking about it.
On the other hand, if we
wanted two teams of 5,
now if we just do 10
choose 5, we're going
to be off, because I
say pick 5 for one team
and the remaining 5 are the other team.
But if I had pick the remaining 5
first, that would have been the same.
Because it's not like I said that
there's a team A and a team B
that have some difference between them.
It's just two teams.
So picking play, again
it helps to label them.
So assume the people are
numbered 1 through 5.
If the teams are 1 through
5 and 6 through 10,
there's only one way to do that.
I'm not designating some
distinction between the two teams.
Therefore, in this case it would
be 10 choose 5 divided by 2
because we've double-counted.
Does everyone understand the
difference between these two things?
Here you're dividing
by 2, here you're not.
Because there is a clear difference
between a team of 4 and a team of 6.
While 2 teams of 5, unless
you said one team is
supposed to wear this jersey and
the other one wears this jersey,
it's equivalent.
So that's a key, sometimes
subtle, distinction
that sometimes gets missed, so I
want to emphasize that a little bit.
So there's a difference there.
So you should think carefully
about issues like that.
It's a little too simplistic to say
order matters or order doesn't matter.
Well, what matters is thinking
in a way that makes sense.
And for this homework, the
naive definition of probability
is enough for all the probability
questions, because that's
the probability we've done so far.
But that doesn't mean you
can just naively apply
the naive definition of probability.
The naive definition assumes
you've broken up your problem
into equally likely outcomes.
So if you break up the problem in
a way where they're clearly not
equally likely, then the naive
definition will not work.
So what I'm saying is, for every
probability question on the homework,
if you frame it in the right way,
you can apply the naive definition.
But you have to think hard
about making sure that it makes
sense to assume equally likely outcomes.
Does that make sense?
So coming back to this sampling table.
So I drew this 2 by 2 table last time.
I won't draw the whole table again.
But you can look it up in
your notes to refresh you.
Three of the four entries--
so the table had sampling
with and without replacement,
and order matters or doesn't matter.
And last time we talked
about the fact that three
of the four entries of the table are
obvious just from the multiplication
rule.
So three of the four
entries you could just
fill in right away once you've
mastered the multiplication rule.
The fourth entry is the tricky one.
So that's the one that I
want to talk about now.
So for the fourth one, I stated
the result. I wrote it down,
but it's mysterious where
it comes from, so I want
to show you where does that come from.
So the problem is, we want to pick
k times from a set of n objects--
could be objects, people, whatever.
And we're looking at the case
where order doesn't matter,
and it's with replacement.
That's the case we're interested in.
So we pick one of the n objects, put
it back, pick another one, put it back.
Do that k times, but
we also don't care--
if we got that same list in a different
order, that counts as the same.
So we want to count how many
ways are there to do this.
And I stated last time that the answer
is n plus k minus 1 choose k ways.
So I want to prove this
result and also give you
a little more intuition for it.
The other three results should
be easy, but this one is tricky.
But first, I should
follow my own advice.
Let's see, is that plausible?
Let's check a couple of
simple and extreme cases.
Well, the most extreme cases--
so extreme cases.
The most extreme example I
can think of is k equals 0.
That is, k equals 0 says
you don't do anything.
So k equals 0.
But let's just see if it makes sense.
Assuming that this is correct, k
equals 0, this is n minus 1 choose 0.
n minus 1 choose 0 is 1.
For the same reasoning,
why is 0 factorial 1?
Well, I always think of factorial
in terms of if you have n people
and they're lined up for ice cream,
how many ways can you order them?
Well, if there is no one
there, there's one way.
It's the way when there's no
one there, there's one way.
0 factorial is 1.
n choose 0 is 1 for any n, because
if you have a group of n people
and you choose none of them,
there's one way to do that.
You just don't choose any one.
So it's 1, not 0, is the key point.
So if you had memorized
and then got confused
whether this was k or n, if you
put n here, then it would be--
but I'm changing k to n in my mind
and let that k be 0. n minus 1
choose n is zero, because you can't
pick n people out of n minus 1.
There's not enough people.
So the answer should be 1,
not 0, so that makes sense.
Let's do a slightly less
extreme case than that.
Well, what if k equals 1?
If k equals 1, then this would
just be n choose 1, which equals n.
Well, that makes sense.
You're just picking once.
Notice, if you only pick
once, it makes no difference
if it's with replacement
or without replacement.
It makes no difference if
it's ordered or unordered.
It has to be n.
So there would be something really
wrong if we didn't get that.
And let's do one other
case that is pretty simple.
Let's do n equals 2.
That's an interesting case for us.
You can try-- n equals 1 is another
easy case, but let's do n equals 2.
n equals 2 is what I would call
the simplest nontrivial example.
One of the best just general pieces
of research advice in general
is to look at the simplest
nontrivial example.
So this one is special in some
sense, simplest nontrivial.
These ones are pretty trivial
but they're still worth checking,
because if they are wrong then
we know there's something wrong.
This is the simplest nontrivial example,
If n equals 2, according
to this formula,
this is going to be k plus 1 choose k.
Notice k plus 1 choose k is the
same thing as k plus 1 choose 1.
Same argument as why is 10
choose 4 the same as 10 choose 6.
You could choose the 4 or
you could choose the 6.
They're the same thing.
This is exactly the same reason.
So that's the same as that.
k plus 1 choose 1 is obviously
k plus 1, because you're
choosing one thing out of k plus 1.
All right, now let's
see if that's correct.
We have n, we have 2 objects
and we are picking k times.
So let's just draw two buckets
to represent the two objects.
And we're picking k times.
So let's just put a--
you can put a check mark,
but for simplicity I'll put a dot
every time I put-- this object 1,
this is object 2.
Every time I select object 1
I'm going to put a dot here.
Every time I select object 2
You can make up some
numbers if you want.
Maybe it looks like that.
I chose object 1 three
times, object 2 four times.
Since it's with replacement,
there's no restriction on how many,
as long as the total equals whatever
the total is supposed to be.
And since order doesn't
matter, I don't actually
care which dot came before which dot.
All I care about is there's
3 dots here and 4 dots here.
Now, it follows from that that,
in order to specify this result,
all we need to do is say how
many dots are there in this box?
Because if I know how many dots are in
this box, then however many are left
are in this one.
So the number of dots here, number
of dots, is in the set 0, 1, up to k,
because I have k dots.
In my example, k is 7, but
k could be whatever, k dots.
So however many are in here-- it
could be that they're all in here,
or none of them, or anything in between.
So there are k plus 1 possibilities.
So just by thinking of this two
boxes, that gives a direct proof
that this is correct in this case.
So that gives us some comfort.
And I'll come back a little
bit to this case, n equals 2.
But now let's prove that this
formula is correct in general.
Well, this dot picture is already
giving us a hint at the problem.
One of the most difficult and most
important things in this course
is to try to get in the habit of trying
to recognize pattern and structure,
that is, recognizing when
two problems are equivalent
even if they sound different.
So that's not a calculus
thing, that's a thinking thing.
You have to think hard.
So the way to think about
this problem, the best way
to think about this problem is not
actually to think of it this way.
It's to notice that this is
equivalent to having indistinguishable
particles in distinguishable boxes.
So I'll just say this is equivalent, and
you can think through for yourself why
is this the same thing.
This is already giving you a hint
as to why this is equivalent,
but you should think about
why this is true in general.
So equivalently, how many ways are there
to put k indistinguishable particles
into n distinguishable boxes?
So I'm thinking of these dots
as indistinguishable particles.
The boxes are distinguishable because
this is box 1 and this is box 2.
k Indistinguishable particles
into n distinguishable boxes.
And the answer is n plus k minus
1 choose k, but let's see why.
Another piece of advice that I could
have added there is draw a diagram
and try some simple examples.
I mentioned the simple examples but
I didn't mention draw a diagram.
I'm just going draw a picture
that should make everything nice.
So suppose we had--
that was a really easy case
where we only had 2 boxes.
Well, let's boldly do 4 boxes.
I can do as many boxes
as I have space for.
It's not any harder.
Once you see the idea, it
could be any number of boxes.
But I'll draw a picture with 4 boxes.
Suppose that this box has 3
particles, this box is empty,
this box has 2 particles,
and this box has 1 particle.
So just for this picture, we had
n equals 4, and we had k equals 6.
Just the number of
particles, number of boxes.
And you could try to draw out.
I wouldn't suggest
doing it for this case.
There's already too many possibilities.
It'll be very tedious
to list them all out.
But you could do one that's somewhere
in between this one and this one
and just try listing out the cases.
Do an example that's simple enough
that's not too tedious just as a check.
But here it's already
getting complicated,
because I can have empty boxes, I
can have all 4 over here, anything.
Now, this idea of
indistinguishability, this
is in contrast to the labeling problem.
So for most real, like, real-life
marbles and things like that,
it behaves more like that,
where you can label them.
But for certain counting problems
and for certain problems in physics,
they are so completely
indistinguishable that you can't even
think of them as labeled.
So, in other words, if I
swapped this one and this one
when you weren't looking, you
would never know the difference.
But not only would you
never know the difference,
god could not tell the difference.
That's this problem here.
Now, usually that's not the case.
So usually we can think
of labeling, where
even if you can't tell the difference
god can tell the difference.
That's the most common scenario.
For some physics problems
it behaves more like this,
and also for some counting problems.
I'm just emphasizing that this is
important in physics, but most of you
are not physicists.
I'm not a physicist.
The reason I'm talking about it is not
because of the physics applications
but because it is
important for counting.
But for probability, usually
with the naive definition,
you're not going to
be able to apply this
because it's going to function more like
the labeled case, not, like this case.
So now, it doesn't look like we've
done anything except draw a picture,
but actually we're basically done
deriving the result. Almost done.
All we need to do is convert this.
This picture will be kind of hard to
type up, even though you can draw this.
Let's convert this into something
simpler that you could actually
write down easier.
So I'm just going to
make up a little code.
This is a very simple code.
I'm going to represent these
dots by dots, so dot, dot, dot.
And then I'm not going
to draw these rectangles.
I'm just going to draw separators.
So I'm going to draw a
vertical line segment
to denote the separators
between boxes, like that.
So the second box was
empty, so therefore I'm
drawing two vertical lines
without any dots in between.
The third box had 2 dots, and
then there is a separator,
and then there's another dot.
So does everyone see what I did?
So it's a very simple encoding.
So notice-- I mean, I just
did this as an example,
but obviously, no matter what
configuration we had drawn here,
that can be encoded in this way,
and you can go from here to here,
you can go from here to here.
It's just a different way to
represent the same situation.
And once we have this we actually
are done, because in this picture
there must be k dots, because there were
k dots here, there must be k dots here.
And there must be n minus 1 separators.
That looks like a 1, but
that's a separator symbol.
Because if I have n boxes, then there's
n minus 1 separators in between.
Now, to specify this, how many
ways are there to do this?
Well, you could think of it as like
the factorial of all these things,
except that that's overcounting.
It's similar to the problem,
like on the strategic practice,
there is a problem like
how many ways are there
to rearrange the letters
of the word pepper?
So it's not just the factorial of
the number of letters in pepper,
because there's multiple
P's and multiple E's and you
have to adjust for that overcounting.
Same as that.
But an even easier
way to think of it is,
to specify this we have n
plus k minus 1 positions here.
And in order to specify
our code, all we need to do
is specify where are the dots.
Choose the positions for the dots.
The remaining positions are the
positions for the separators.
So n plus k minus 1 choose k.
There isn't even anything
else I can write.
This is self-annotating again.
I have n plus k minus 1 positions
here, and I'm going to pick k of them
to put the dots.
If you want, you could also say this
is n plus k minus 1 choose n minus 1.
Choose where the dots are and
the separators are determined,
or choose where the separators are
and then the dots are determined.
Same thing.
So that completes the
proof of that result.
So just coming back
very briefly to this n
equals 2 case, a case where
you could think of that would
be if you imagine flipping two coins.
Usually, we think of
that as having four--
assume they're fair coins, so
heads and tails are equally likely.
Usually we think of four equally
likely outcomes-- heads heads,
heads tails, tails heads, tails tails.
So there's four of them.
Now, suppose the coins look
completely indistinguishable to you.
Still, we could imagine that there's
coin number 1 and coin number 2.
Or, rather than thinking
of flipping two coins,
we could think of flipping
the same coin twice.
So we have the first
toss and the second toss.
So even if the coins look the same to
you, we would think of four outcomes.
Does that make sense?
Heads heads, heads tails,
tails heads, tails tails.
A massive controversy in
physics arose in the 1920s
when a young Indian physicist named
Bose proposed, not for coins--
he was doing a particle
physics problem--
but what he was saying
was equivalent for coins
as saying that there are only
three outcomes, not four,
and all are equally likely.
Because, in terms of
coins, we'll be saying,
well, either it's heads heads, tails
tails, or one head and one tail.
And if the coins are
completely indistinguishable,
so you can't distinguish between
heads tails and tails heads.
So he was proposing a
model in physics, not
for coins, where there were three
equally likely outcomes, not four.
And he basically got
laughed at for that.
But he wrote a letter to
a guy called Einstein,
and Einstein really liked the idea.
And then they were able to
finally start convincing people.
That was in the 1920s.
So they actually used
something-- and this just
looks like a simple
little counting thing--
but ideas along these lines in
physics, they used these tips
to predict a new state of matter
called the Bose-Einstein condensate.
They predicted that theoretically.
It was only empirically
observed 70 years later,
so they predicted it
70 years in advance.
This is not a physics class, but you
can look that up if you're curious.
It has all kinds of bizarre properties.
The point of this, though, is that, for
coins, the thinking of it as labeled,
whether you can tell them apart or
not, is normally the right way to go.
So this is useful for
counting and for physics,
but you have to be careful
about using this with the naive
definition of probability.
So let's talk a little more about
counting and what I call story proofs.
So let's start with a simple example.
So a story proof is still a proof,
otherwise I wouldn't call it a proof.
Someone asked whether
that means an example.
What it means is an application
or an interpretation.
So proof by interpretation,
I would say, rather than
proof by algebra or calculus.
So there are some examples
on the strategic practice,
and I just want to do a
couple more quick examples.
Then we're ready to go beyond the
naive definition of probability.
So proof by interpretation,
what do I mean by that?
Well, we already saw an example today.
We proved that 10 choose
4 equals 10 choose 6.
So, in general, n choose k
equals n choose n minus k.
That's a very useful fact.
And I'm not going to
write the proof again.
This one is-- so this is example 1.
This one is easy to do
using algebra as well.
But it's even easier to just
say, well, if I pick k out of n,
or I could pick the other
n minus k, and you could
write one sentence explaining that.
But I already talked about that,
so I'm not going write that again.
It's the same idea.
So this is obvious by the story.
The story is just the interpretation
that we are picking k people out of n,
rather than just thinking of this as
a formal symbol involving factorials
that you manipulate.
That's actually thinking about what
this means rather than manipulating
factorials.
That's what I mean by that.
OK, let's do a slightly
harder one, and then one
that would be a nightmare using algebra.
So here's kind of an
intermediate example.
This is a very handy identity.
That n minus 1 choose k minus
1 equals k times n choose k.
So I didn't memorize.
I've used this identity
many, many times in my life.
But I don't like memorizing things,
so I wrote this kind of slowly
because I didn't remember
it, I just derived it.
Again, you can check this
by algebra pretty easily,
but that's not going to help you
remember it or understand it.
That's just like you could
write out the algebra
and it will just look like a curiosity.
Oh, it cancels out and so you know.
It doesn't give you any
intuition for why that's true.
So the story proof for this
would be to imagine that we're
going to pick k people out of n.
And, of course, it
doesn't have to be people.
It can be whatever example
you want, but the point
is you're not losing any generality.
I'm not saying 3 people or something.
It's still a general interpretation.
It doesn't matter that
I said it's people.
Pick k people out of n, with one of
them designated as the president, say,
or whatever you want to call the title.
That is, you have a
committee and there's
a chair of a committee, or a president,
or whatever, the president of the club.
So I want to know how many
ways are there to do that.
Well, there's two different
approaches I could take.
Either I could first
select who's in the club.
There are k people in my club.
There are n people in the population,
there are k people in my club.
So I could pick who's
in the club, n choose k.
And then one of those k must be elected
as president, so we multiply by k.
Multiplication rule.
Choose who's in the club,
then choose the president.
That's this.
But I could also just say,
first choose the president.
And then once I have
the president, then I
need k minus 1 more people
in my club, and those could
be any of the remaining n minus 1.
That is again the motivation rule.
They are the same thing.
That's a proof.
That's a completely
rigorous mathematical proof,
but it also gives you
some interpretation.
So that's the kind of thing
that I mean, that we're counting
the same thing in two different ways.
So if both ways are correct,
they must agree, right?
So that's the idea.
So count the same thing in two ways.
And one more example that will be
useful several times in this course.
It's a handy identity.
Suppose we had m plus n choose k,
and I want to write this as a sum.
Usually, it goes the other
way around, that we're going
to see a sum that looks like this.
So we're going to sum j equals 0 to
k of m choose j, n choose k minus j.
So suppose we have this sum, and we want
to prove that this sum just collapses
just to this one binomial coefficient.
This is a famous identity in math
called Vandermonde's identity.
It comes up actually a lot
in different areas of math,
and especially in probability, but it
also comes up outside of probability.
So if you try to derive this one
using algebra, it's pretty horrible.
I mean, you write all this
in terms of factorials,
you can try to cancel stuff, but you
still have to deal with this sum.
You can try to apply
the binomial theorem.
You can do a lot of stuff
but it's not easy at all.
So let's prove this using a story.
Well, here again, it's very helpful
that this is self-annotating.
You don't have to be that smart to think
of, well, this is m plus n choose k,
so I'm going to think about
picking k people out of m plus n.
That's what it says to do, right?
So that's what I'm going to do.
I'm going to pick k out of
m plus n, that's the story.
Now I have to say, well, of
course clearly that's this,
but how does that
relate to the sum here?
How does that relate to
picking k out of m plus n?
Well, m plus n is kind
of self-annotating also.
It means I have an m and I have
an n I added them together.
So I'm imagining two groups--
a group of size m and a group of
size n, and together it's m plus n.
So that seems like a
pretty natural thing to do.
I mean, that's what m plus n means.
So we have a group of m.
Here's m people.
And I'm not going to try to
draw stick figures or anything,
but these dots represent people,
not indistinguishable particles.
So you should think of
these people as labeled.
If you want, you can
call this person 1, 2, 3.
So 1 through m are in this group.
And then n.
Maybe m is 3 and n is 5.
Here's n people.
So maybe I'll number these 1 through
3, and these ones are 4, 5, 6, 7, 8,
or however you want to label them.
Now I need to select k people
from, total, from these two groups.
So maybe I picked--
I'll just circle the ones I picked.
Maybe I picked this one,
this one, this one, that one.
I picked 4 of them, for example.
Well, let's pick 5 of them.
There.
So how many ways are there to do that?
Well, obviously I need to pick some
number of people from this group
and some number from this
group such that the total is k.
So suppose that I picked
j from here, picked j.
And suppose I picked--
well.
So in this case j is 2, I
picked 2 from this group.
I don't know why the
projector is going on.
I picked j from this group,
j is 2 in this example.
If I need 5 total and I picked 2
from here, there must be 3 from here.
Obviously, right?
So this is just k
minus j from over here.
If there's j here, there
must be k minus j here.
How many ways are there to
pick j here, k minus j here?
Well, it's just this, right?
That's the multiplication rule.
Then we add those up.
We're not double counting anything,
we're just adding up disjoint cases.
So we just add them up and that's that.
And that's the proof.
That's it.
Just writing up a few sentences
about that in words, that's a proof,
and it's a lot better to do it that way
than to try to do that using algebra.
So last thing for today is to
start, just very briefly start,
on the non-naive
definition of probability,
and then obviously we'll be continuing
that for the rest of the semester.
But I just want to get the
basic structure in place.
So here's the general
definition of probability.
Up until now, we were assuming
equally likely outcomes.
And we want to go beyond that.
We don't want to assume
everything is equally likely,
and we don't want to have to
assume that there are only
finitely many possible outcomes.
We want to go beyond that.
So this is the non-naive definition.
For the non-naive definition, we need
the notion of a probability space.
And I already introduced the
concept of a sample space.
So a probability space consists of two
ingredients, which I'll call S and P.
And I just have to tell you what S
and P are and what rules they obey.
So S-- the same notation
we used before--
S is a sample space.
Remember, that's just the set of all
possible outcomes of some experiment,
and we'll interpret the word
experiment very broadly.
So S is a sample space.
I already talked about what that means.
Up until now, we had to assume that this
was finite and that all of the outcomes
were equally likely.
And now we're going to
go way, way beyond that
and not have to assume that any more.
So P is a function.
But it's not the kind of
function that you usually see,
like f of x equals x squared.
The domain of P is all subsets
of S. So P is a function.
It's a mapping that takes as
an input, it takes an event.
Remember, we talked before-- and there's
also a handout that you should look
at, if you haven't already--
an event is a subset of S.
So P is a function which
takes an event, any event A--
I'll just call it A--
an event A, which is a
subset of S, as input.
So an event is a subset of
S-- that's the subset symbol--
input, and gives P of A, which
is a number between 0 and 1.
Because we want probabilities,
just by convention,
standard convention is
that we want probabilities
to be numbers between 0 and 1.
So the input is an event, the
output is a number between 0 and 1.
So that's the output.
Now, the only thing left
is I have to tell you
what axioms does this have to satisfy?
In other words, what properties do we
need P to satisfy, aside from the fact
that it's between 0 and 1?
So you might think that a probability
is a very complicated thing,
like understanding uncertainty
is a very complicated thing.
But actually we only need
two axioms, two rules.
So such that, rule number 1, the
probability of the empty set equals 0,
and the probability of
the full space equals 1.
And you might say I cheated by
including two things in one.
Actually, you can try to
simplify the axioms and derive,
and you could try to
derive this, but I'm not
trying to make this completely minimal.
I like to write it this way
because these are the two extremes.
The probability of the
empty set equals 0.
That makes sense intuitively.
What would it mean for
the empty set to occur?
We say that an event occurs if--
so our set up is we have this--
Venn diagrams are useful here.
S is like the universe
of all possible outcomes.
And we get one specific--
let's say this is A is this oval.
And let's suppose that
s-- that's a lowercase
s but I did it big so that it's visible.
That lowercase s0 is an
example of an outcome.
So our picture is, before
we do the experiment,
we just have this general sample space.
After we do the experiment, then
we get to observe the outcome.
And suppose that the actual
outcome of the experiment was s0.
Now, if that actual
outcome is an element of A,
then we say that A occurred.
And if this s0 is outside of
A, we say it doesn't occur.
Now, what would it mean
for the empty set to occur?
It would mean that this
s0 is in the empty set.
But nothing is in the empty set.
It's empty.
So that's why I want this to be 0.
What that's saying is we want
impossible events to have probability 0.
This is impossible.
This, on, the other hand, S
itself happens with certainty.
If somehow s0 fell
outside of that rectangle,
that would mean you had
the wrong rectangle.
This is the whole universe here.
So it can't be outside.
So that's 1.
That's basically a convention.
The most important axiom is the second
one, and luckily there's only two.
So you're not going to
have to memorize 10 axioms.
It's just two simple rules.
So, just very quickly,
the second one says
that the probability of the union--
so I'm assuming that
you know unions now.
This is called a countable union.
That is, I'm taking a
union of infinitely many,
but it's called a
countably infinitely many.
So the probability of the union
equals the sum of the probabilities.
And there's an important
condition there.
That's true if the A1, A2,
et cetera are disjoint, which
just means that no two of them overlap.
So I'll just say non-overlapping.
So those are the two
axioms of probability.
And I find it pretty amazing that, from
these two simple rules, we can derive--
every single theorem and
result in probability
eventually follows from these two rules.